(light airy music)
(chair squeaks)
(squeak)
(inhales deeply)
- Now I dive into your virgin sea.
(bag crumples)
EmuNET for personal use is so wrong,
but feels so good.
Kalan, your performance is below sub-par.
Please see Anna for
career and life advice.
(light airy music)
(creamer gushes)
♫ 'Cause I'm Slim Shady,
yes I'm the real Shady.
♫ All you other Slim
Shadys are just imitaties.
♫ Oh, won't the real Slim Shady
♫ Please stand up, please
stand up, please stand up.
(microwave runs)
No one notices your biceps, Kalan.
(light airy music)
Kalan, please un-pop your collar.
I have important news.
The results of the internal audit are in,
and it turns out I'm the real Slim Shady
and all the other Slim
Shadys are just imitating.
So what does that make you, Kalan?
(light airy music)
(phone rings)
(sighs)
- Don't you love coming in early?
Don't have to deal with anyone's nonsense.
- Yeah.
- ♫ I'm Slim Shady,
yes I'm the real Shady.
♫ All you other Slim
Shadys are just imitating
(mumbles)
You remember that song?
- [woman] Hmm?
- You remember that song? It's Eminem's.
It's good.
It's kind of older, though, but...
It's like,
♫ I'm Slim Shady, yes I'm the real Shady.
I'll play it for you later.
(deep inspiring music)